welcome back
we're on episode 2 of cmake if you
haven't watched the first one
i would highly recommend watching the
first one before watching this otherwise
you're going to be
a little bit confused unless you're
already really good with cmake
so we're going to pick up from right
where we left off basically this time
i'm going to talk about levels libraries
and i'm really going to be mainly
talking about
static libraries here so we're going to
go ahead and open up visual studio
code and i'm going to go to
file open folder
and we're going to look for the project
we started last time
our lord and savior click ok
there we go so all we have since last
time is
a minimum required version rc make a
project an executable so what if we want
to do more with this executable
we've just got this little main it
doesn't do a whole lot other than spit
out hey zeus how you doing zeus
nice just nice to talk to you whatever
you know
so you can add more files to this
say you want more files in your
project so what you can do is just hit
of course
new file make a new file however you
want so i'm just going to make another
file
called uh cisco with like an adder dot
cpp
all right so we get an adder.cpp
all we got to do is just add it to this
list right here
this to just be like i don't know just
have a function
or a class or something like that or we
just have a void
uh ad or we could get fancy and overload
this and stuff but i'm not i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna use floats
of course we gotta return a float and
we're basically just gonna return
a plus b completely useless function
really because it just does something so
simple that you won't need a function
for it
but i'm just using it to get a point
across
all right so then if we go and test out
our adder we'll say
add 72.1
plus 73 point
something and then we'll put a new line
here
well we'll do it like this so i don't
flush
and now it doesn't see this ad of course
because we'll need to include it
well we need a header for it basically
it needs to know about the function
so if we do an include of adder.cbp
it'll bring this code over into this
file which isn't
what we want here really we want a
proper
header of it so it would be like float
head and there we go and the definitions
somewhere else
so we're fine and of course these should
have a little
f on them otherwise it might be a little
confused
um and of course i don't need a plus
here i need a comma
all right and that should add them
together
so if we go back to our cmake we've
already got the adder in there
and now we can just compile so i'll open
up my terminal
and we'll just uh
we'll rerun the cmake thing we'll go
cmake
sources here build into
out slash build there we go
and then we'll run make
and dash c to go down into the directory
with
make that's just a make thing build
there we go
so it built the target didn't have any
errors
and now we should be able to run it so
we'll just go
to where it is
and there we go we got our result
so there we had it in there now usually
you'll have classes and usually you'll
just include the header
so this is just kind of very simple
example of just adding the function
adding a different file and how you can
have as many as you want on this list to
compile into your main object there
all right so now we're going to talk
about adding libraries
let's say
we want to add a library
for this adder thing instead of and just
compile it into our object
it'll essentially do the same thing but
rather than building in with the object
it'll build it separately and then
link it at the end using the linker
whole c plus plus thing
so that might be confusing to you if
you're not super familiar with c plus
plus
but if you are it's going to be like
yeah yeah i know
so we're just going to do that we're
going to build this adder as a library
so to do that we are going to need a
header
and we're actually going to put this in
its own little folder so let's create a
new folder and we'll name this folder
um header we'll use the capital a
put the cpp in there confirm
go over here and just add another new
file adder.h
we're going to go ahead and i think turn
this into a class
because why not we don't have to um yeah
that's not
so we'll just put the header here float
batter float a float
b and of course you can make whatever
function you want just you know add or
simple all right
then we define it here of course this
needs to know about
the header part so
there we go and now we want to build
this separately
and then link it to our main so what
we're going to do here is just add
another cmakelist.txt in this one
see make list dot t list dot txt
there's actually multiple ways of doing
this i'm just showing you the way of
doing it when it's in a new directory
because so you have a sub level
cmakelist.txt
and that's kind of what i'm talking
about with levels we're going to do add
sub directory and the subdirectory is
header so basically we reference
let me just like open this open
containing folder
might be easier to explain this way all
right so we have our top level
cmakelist.txt
and then the subdirectory adder will
just go in here and look for
cmakelist.text
so this isn't the root header one
so it doesn't have to have all the same
thing you don't need a project
really all you need is just like
something like this
add library and you give the library
name
we'll give it the name adder and we'll
say it needs to compile with adder.cpp
and that's basically it that'll build it
as a library in the most simplistic way
possible so now when we go back to here
this right here will
build that library but we do need to
link the library to our
core project so we go target link
library and the project well it's going
to be our project name oh last so we'll
just use this macro in case we
change the name at some point or
something like that
and the library is going to be
adder
oh lowercase lowercase adder
so it does need to match that otherwise
it will never find it
okay so from here it should build our
main
it should then build the library
and then before doing its final build
it'll link adder to the executable
so let's just go run cmake now so we'll
go back to our terminal
and just rerun our cmake we're in the
the root directory of our folder so
the root one is still the same place the
build is still in the same place
and we got a little error command oh
it's because i'm
putting these semicolons on the end like
a derp try not to be a dirt
that's my job not your job all right
so let's go back in here let's do it
again
and target link library is apparently
incorrect
so what is it is it target
blank libraries
it's not library it's libraries so if
you have multiple libraries you want to
link them all at once you can start
putting more libraries in here
this is how you link your libraries to
your project if you've got them
somewhere else being built so
that was successful now all we got to do
is run our make
and then run the program make
dash capital c to run it down in the
directory and there we go
looks like it had a problem add was not
declared in this scope
so another thing you need to do in your
main of course it doesn't know where
this ad is just because you linked it
you know least you just need to have the
header
so the header of is of course the adder
and it is down a directory adder
adder dot h
just got to go down in that directory
into this one and of course
we're going to need these quotes and
since we didn't
add or remove any files we don't have to
run
the cmake thing again not necessary we
just need to redo
the build which is this make command
it looks like it's still a little
confused what did i do wrong
okay so we added the library
we added the subdirectory which should
build the library and then
we do this ad now why is this confused
it says
it is undefined all right so in here
we want to go target link directories
and target of course is this project
name
and basically
this is going to be that header folder
so that's
the directory so this basically tells it
where to find
the adder uh
linker library since we put it in its
own folder we've got to do target link
directories and there's a directory for
our linkers right there so if you've got
them down in folders
you're going to have to specify where
those libraries you need to link are
with this on your target this should now
be fine let's go ahead and configure
again
target link directories target link with
invalid arguments
okay so the invalid argument here is
we need to specify whether this is
public or private we're going to just
say private and that just basically
means
it's not going to add it for anything
else beyond it's just this but basically
we need to give it
a visibility level private's going to be
fine in our case since we're not doing a
whole lot else
let's rerun cmake it's now happy let's
now run
make and
it's still not happy why can't you just
be happy
why we'll take it a step further
and we'll also put in here
include directories
i believe let's just tell it where the
includes are that way we don't have to
specify
way down and this should just be
adder
taking it from the root and then just
down a folder
so that way we don't have to make this
any more specific
than just hey there's a header because
now cmake will tell it
that directory all right let's go ahead
and run this again
incorrect number of arguments all righty
do we also need to privatize
this we'll do this as public here
oh and this says project's name it's
project
so that's probably there it was heaven
and
purblick is is also not a keyword so
public let's go with public
so it's actually going to be building
down in here
there it is there is live
adder you know i've been messing with
this the whole time like it's a c make
problem
well i've showed you a ton of things so
that's cool but the entire problem and
maybe you guys already caught this is
i named the header definition one adder
and i named
the actual instantiation of it just had
so of course it's not
going to work so that was just me
derping a little bit had nothing to do
with really anything else but
it's kind of kind of give me the chance
to show you guys a super example
of how to do all this other stuff anyway
so
now we should work without any issues
let's go ahead and build that there we
go
build now we just want to run it which
is center out and it's in our build
let me just do a allow out build
and you can see it there it's got the
adder folder as well
so let's just let's just take a gander
at this folder real quick before we run
it open containing folder
here it is there's the the build
so yeah we've got the adder library
there ready to be
linked and we've got
our make file of course now let's just
take a peek at this make file
open it with feather pad nice and bright
sorry about your eyes
all right default target all so if you
just run plane make it's going to build
all so we'll go ahead and look for this
all there should be
somewhere in here called all
so that's basically what it's going to
run
so cma check and build it's going to
start doing all this stuff
so this looks a little confusing and
that's fine you don't really need to
understand this all you basically just
need to get your cmake list off text
correct
but make files are what everything turns
into as i talked about last episode so
it is nice to understand those
you just don't ever need to edit this so
basically you can learn make files or
learn make or learn cmake and you might
as well learn
cmake because it does a lot more than
just make files
there's make files you just need a
broader
more dense understanding to get its work
correctly cmake just
handles a lot of stuff for you which is
nice but it doesn't hurt to have that
broad knowledge too so if you want to
study make files
that's fine
as a quick review here we have gone the
extra mile
and we've added a subdirectory called
adder
which just is this folder with another
cmake and it all has his ad library that
builds these into a library
so you can expand this any way you want
you can build libraries however you want
that way
and then we did a target include
directories
uh for this folder that way when we
include
we can just do it this really standard
way instead of having to specifically
path to the folder like so and then
target link directories
is where your libraries are going to be
now this is
pathing from your build folder basically
so it starts from wherever your output
is
from when you run this here l
and of course we have the adder folder
so we're gonna say it's in there
in target link libraries just links that
library
to our project and that's it hopefully
this hasn't been too confusing for you
guys so far it's been kind of a lot of
information
but this is how you make libraries
so we kind of talked about levels and
lives now let's talk about sub modules
now this is a get
thing so it's a little getting a little
bit into version control
and it also so i'll talk a little bit
about git
or you know i'll just save this for the
next episode episode three because this
one's already getting to be a bit
long but i think i got the point of
levels and lives
across pretty well tune in next episode
i'll release in a couple days of sub
modules
i was also going to answer questions in
this one about the first one but i
didn't get any questions so i guess it
was clear enough i know i missed
a couple words in episode 1 but i guess
people got the point so
please let me know if you have any
questions i'll be sure to answer them in
next episode
as long as it's not too late but as long
as the series is going i will try to
answer questions that come up
and uh yeah next time we're just going
to focus on sub modules it might be a
kind of quick one
it's uh it's really cool it's basically
how to add libraries
from github repositories and it's
it's another thing that really sold me
on cmake so we'll keep going with this
there's going to be a lot of episodes
and this is going to be going on for a
while because there's just a lot you can
do
with cmake so stay tuned
hit the subscribe button to be notified
when those go live and
i do a lot of other tutorials also don't
forget to hit like and help this channel
over and out stay healthy
peace out